we've got to get to the really important
stories now
that would be the 81 year old woman
gracing the cover of Sports Illustrated
this has created some controversy
and if I got a weigh in on on just
aesthetically speaking how the cover
looks
Martha Stewart looks great
certainly for an 81 year old woman
certainly for a 71 year old woman
certainly for a 61 year old woman
she frankly looks great for like a 51
year old woman
maybe even a woman in her 40s it is
shocking how good Martha Stewart looks I
don't only say this because Martha
Stewart is a great
basically wholesome traditional cultural
figure by the way it's not like she's
wearing a bikini or something in this
it's a pretty tasteful
Sports Illustrated cover
but we all suspect something that's kind
of wrong with this
so it just feels wrong to have an 81
year old on your swimsuit cover right
but people are having trouble putting
their finger on exactly what's wrong
about it for one she's she's a woman
that's more than can be said of sports
illustrated's cover in in recent years
there's there is a transsexual a trans
identifying man in the uh this this
issue as well
now part of why Sports Illustrated does
this is because Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit Issue is an anachronism it used
to be really kind of fun and titillating
back in the 90s even the 2000s back
before the ubiquity of Hardcore internet
pornography back when people would go
down to the newsstand back when those
still existed and they'd buy the
magazine and say we're going to see some
pretty women wearing not a lot of
clothing but now you go on the internet
whatever the most depraved disorder
desire you can possibly imagine is you
can multiply it by 300 and you can find
it the click of a of a button so Sports
Illustrated in order to stay relevant to
stay in the news
it has to create controversy and one way
to create controversy is to pretend that
dudes are chicks which is obviously
completely disgusting but at least gets
them in the news and then a better way
for them to create controversy is to put
an 81 year old woman on the cover so
okay mission accomplished they did that
but why is it wrong why is it wrong
that even this very good looking woman
at 81 years old is Undercover I go back
to a line from
Saint Gregory the Great which has been
popularized in recent years by Saint
Jose Maria scriva which is that
it is not good to look at what it is not
listed to desire
and I'm not going to use this line in
its precision
I just mean it as a way to sort of get
at why people feel like it's a little
bit wrong to have an 81 year old woman
wearing a swimsuit on the cover of this
magazine right now go to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles when you want
to hire the best people you've got to
check out ziprecruiter.com Knowles
hiring used to be really hard you would
post your job on multiple sites hope the
right people see it and then wait for
them to apply same goes for finding a
job you upload your resume to every job
posting site comb through never-ending
lists of jobs trying to find the right
position for you zip recruiter is the
best place to find the right position or
if you're an employer the right person
to head your team or to join your team
so right now go to ziprecruiter.com
knowleskin w-l-e-s try it for free ZIP
recruiters matching technology excels at
finding the most qualified candidates
for a wide range of roles if you see a
candidate you like you can easily send
that person a personal invite so that
he's more likely to apply four out of
five employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day see for yourself go to
ziprecruiter.com
to try ZipRecruiter for free that is
zip router the smartest way to hire
right now go to puretalk.com Knowles do
you remember the last time you got a
free phone you started out feeling great
and then came the Hefty activation fees
the four line requirements and of course
that binding contract Pure Talk is
giving you a free 5G Samsung Galaxy
phone without the feeling that you've
been duped when you switch to Pure talks
unlimited talk and text data plan that
comes with a mobile hotspot you will get
a 5G Samsung Galaxy for free that's
right unlimited everything at a fraction
of the price at Verizon ATT T-Mobile
here's another thing you'll be on
America's Most Dependable 5G Network
not just a similar Network they'd be on
the same one how do I know I'm a
customer make the switch to Pure Talk
the cell phone Wireless company that I
am proud to stand behind because they
have a fabulous service and they are
proud to stand behind our mission at the
daily wire there are us-based customer
service team which frankly is reason
enough to switch can help you switch in
as little as 10 minutes you can even
keep your own phone number go to
puretalk.com Knowles for your free
Samsung Galaxy when you sign up for
unlimited talk text and unlimited data
that is puretalk.com
Wireless for Americans by Americans
we think it's wrong because we know it's
not
we should we should not be
sexually Desiring an 81 year old woman
even an 81 year old woman who's a
beloved cultural figure who looks very
very good especially for age it's just
that's not right
it makes sense to sexually desire
when you're a young man and you're
single and you're looking at a date and
get married it makes sense to desire
the women around your age
and then to follow that desire by asking
the girl out to get a drink or to get
dinner and then to follow that desire by
dating for a period of time then to
follow that desire by getting married
and follow that desire by doing that
thing that Mary Pebbles do and then to
follow that desire by creating children
as a result of your your physical
expression of that Bond of love that
love which becomes so real that it
actually becomes expressed in a new
person and to allow that love to deepen
and to desire in a way that changes and
deepens and grows over time your spouse
until both of you are 81 and you're
sitting on a porch somewhere sipping
iced tea looking at all your kids and
grandkids that makes sense
but it's kind of weird for a young man
who are supposedly the people who are
buying the Sports Illustrated swimsuit
issue
to be ogling an 81 year old a woman who
could be their grandmother that's wrong
and even if Martha Stewart I don't know
if she's had any work done give Martha
the benefit of the dad but let's assume
like most celebrities she said like
maybe just a little bit of work here and
there she's got personal trainers at
least in good diet and let's assume that
there's some airbrushing going on in
Photoshop to kind of make the picture
look a little bit better
it's
it's wrong to feel that desire even if
you say the whole concept of the
swimsuit issue is a little bit wrong
because it's inciting lust or something
which again that's a whole separate
argument
but whatever it is
it's not meant
for 81 year olds that's just not
appropriate
and
radicals want to distill all of life
down to three bullet points on a napkin
that they can call their political
Manifesto but life is more complex than
that
and one way to approach these kinds of
thoughts is
with moderation and with prudence and
with practical wisdom and with
recognizing that things are meant to be
in their proper place when a man behaves
like a woman that's improper that's
womanish
when a woman behaves like a woman that's
proper that's womanly they're both
behaving like women why can't they do
that well because one is not proper to
their nature and one is proper to their
nature
and the nature of the Sports Illustrated
swimsuit issue is that it is not proper
for an 81 year old woman to be on the
cover no matter how good she looks how'd
you like that clip hope you did I liked
it I thought it was pretty good
subscribe
ring that Bell make sure you get all the
notifications for the Michael Knowles
Channel we'll see you next time